[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing an important piece
of harry potter history that many of you
may not know about
what is it exactly oh only a harry
potter prequel written by jk rowling
herself
in 2008 jk rowling along with 12 other
authors
were invited by uk bookseller
waterstones to contribute
handwritten cards to a charity auction
named what's your story
the purpose of the auction was to raise
money for sufferers of
dyslexia and the way that the money was
meant to be raised
was through selling custom story cards
written
by each author that was invited
originally waterstones just expected the
authors to write a small blurb
nothing major however rowling took it to
the next level
and ended up writing a short but very
legitimate
harry potter prequel the cards from the
13 participating authors
which included rowling's were auctioned
on the 10th of june
2008 and raised a total of 47
150 pounds however rowling's card was
responsible
for a whopping 25 000 of this selling
for more than all of the other cards
combined
in the end a tokyo-based investment
banker ended up buying the original
prequel written by rowling on the card
i'm going to share the prequel with you
guys
but first let's say what rowling had to
say about the whole ordeal
a few months ago a number of authors
were invited to hand write cards for
auction by waterstones
on june 10th all proceeds to go to
english pen
the writers association and the dyslexia
action
after playing around with a number of
different ideas i decided to write a
short
for me excerpt from a prequel to the
potter series
it is about 800 words long and the
action takes place around
three years before harry is born
although i did feel a bit like a
relapsing addict as i sat down to write
the words poured from my pen with
frightening ease according to
rowling's comments the prequel takes
place around three years before harry
was born
which would make it set in the year 1977
the same year that james potter
sirius black and the other marauders
were attending their seventh year at
hogwarts
for this reason the untitled prequel has
been aptly named
the james and sirius prequel it's also
known as the marauders prequel
without further ado let's get into it
the speeding motorcycle took the sharp
corner so fast in the darkness
that both policemen in the pursuing car
shouted whoa
sergeant fisher slammed his large foot
on the brake thinking that the boy who
was riding pillion
was sure to be flung under his wheels
however the motorbike made the turn
without unseating either of its riders
and with a wink of its red taillight
vanished at the narrow side street we've
got him now
crying to pc anderson excitedly that's a
dead end
leaning hard on the steering wheel and
crashing his gears the fischer scraped
half the paint off the flank of the car
as he forced it up the alleyway in
pursuit
there in the headlights sat their quarry
stationary at last after a quarter of an
hour's chase
the two riders were trapped between a
towering brick wall and the police car
which was now crashing towards them like
some growling luminous-eyed predator
there was so little space between the
car doors and the walls of the alley
that fisher and anderson had difficulty
extricating themselves
from the vehicle it injured their
dignity to have to inch
crab-like towards the miscreants fisher
dragged his generous belly along the
wall
tearing buttons of his shirt as he went
and finally snapping off the wing mirror
with his backside
get off the bike he bellowed the
smirking youths who sat basking in the
flashing blue light
as though enjoying it they did as they
were told finally pulling free from the
broken wind mirror
fischer glared at them they seemed to be
in their late teens
the one who'd been driving had long
black hair his insolent good looks
reminded fisher unpleasantly
of his daughter's guitar playing
layabout boyfriend
the second boy also had black hair
though his was short and stuck up in all
directions
he wore glasses and a broad grin both
were dressed in t-shirts
emblazoned with a large golden bird the
emblem
no doubt of some deafening tuneless rock
band
no helmets fisher yelled pointing from
one uncovered head to the other
exceeding the speed limit by by a
considerable amount
in fact the speed registered had been
greater than fischer was prepared to
accept that any motorcycle could travel
failing to stop for the police we'd have
loved to stop for a chat
said the boeing glasses only we were
trying don't get smart
you two were in a heap of trouble
snarled anderson names
names repeated the long head driver uh
well
let's see there's wilberforce bathsheba
elvendork and what's nice about that one
is you can use it for a boy
or a girl said the boy in glasses oh our
names did you mean
asked the first as anderson splutted
with rage you should have said
this here is james potter and i'm sirius
black
things will be seriously back for you in
a minute you cheeky little
but neither james nor sirius was paying
attention
they were suddenly as alert as gundogs
staring past fischer and anderson
over the roof of the police car at the
dark mouth of the alley
then with identical fluid movements they
reached into their back pockets
for the space of a heartbeat both
policemen imagined guns gleaming at them
but a second later they saw that the
motorcyclists
had drawn nothing more than drumsticks
jade anderson
right pair of jokers aren't you right
we're arresting you on a charge of
but anderson never got to name the
charge james and sirius had shouted
something incomprehensible
and the beams from the headlights had
moved the policemen
wheeled around then staggered backwards
three men were flying
actually flying up the alley on
broomsticks and at the same moment the
police car was rearing up on its back
wheels
fisher's knees bucked he sat down hard
anderson tripped over fish's legs and
fell on top of him
as flump bang crunch they heard the men
on brooms
slam into the upended car and fall
apparently
insensible to the ground while broken
bits of broomstick clattered down around
them
the motorbike had roared into life again
his mouth hanging open
fischer mustered the strength to look
back the two teenagers
thanks very much called sirius of the
throb of the engine
we owe you one yeah nice meeting you
said james
and don't forget elvendork it's unisex
there was an earth-shattering crash and
fischer and anderson
threw their arms around each other in
fright their car had just fallen back to
the ground
now it was the motorcycle's turn to rear
before the policeman's disbelieving eyes
it took off into the air james and
sirius zoomed away into the night sky
their taillight twinkling behind them
like a vanishing ruby
from the prequel i am not working on but
that was fun
jk rowling 2008 the synopsis of the
above passage
in essence is this two muggle policemen
chase a speeding motorbike ridden by
sirius black and james potter
when the policemen corner them they
confront the pair and it's at this point
that three men
fly down the alley on broomsticks james
and sirius magically upend the
policeman's car
and the broomsticks crash into it
rendering their riders insensible
as the policemen clutch at each other in
fear sirius and james return to their
motorbike
which then flies away pretty interesting
and important piece of harry potter
history
if you ask me i should also mention that
the handwritten story card
containing the prequel was actually
later stolen during a burglary carried
out in birmingham in 2017.
to this day the location of the stolen
manuscript is not known
but i do certainly hope it shows up one
day
and that's it for this video did you
know about this prequel
comment down below until next time
remember
time will not slow down when something
unpleasant lies ahead
you